quelques fleurs et du recueillement en
apprenant la mort de l'homme d'état dont
une majorité de français se sentait
proche
ils sont venus lui dire adieu cprk alain
de la famille je sais je vous ai un ami
j'aimais beaucoup ça faisait peur parce
que je ammar a connu jacques chirac
alors qu'il briguait la mairie de paris
un poste qu'il a occupé pendant près de
20 ans il montre le cadre qui en est le
mur de son séjour retraçant chacune de
leurs rencontres
celui que l'on surnommait le bulldozers
à ses débuts s'est imposé sur la scène
politique française pendant un
demi-siècle protégés de pompidou et de
gaulle
il a été ministre et premier ministre
après deux échecs consécutifs
il réalise enfin le rêve d'être élu
président de la république en 1995 il
restera à la tête de l'état pendant 12
ans l'un de ses premiers gestes qu'ils
proclament pour la première fois la
responsabilité de la france dans la
déportation et l'extermination des juifs
la france a accompli l'irréparable at il
dit le président chirac c'est aussi
celui qui a dit non aux ambitions de
guerre en irak du président george w
bush
tout comme le canada d'ailleurs l'irak
ne représente pas aujourd'hui une menace
immédiate elle qu'elle justifie une
guerre du médiocre la fin de sa carrière
politique a été noircie par ses déboires
judiciaires
privé de l'immunité que la présidence
lui conférait jacques chirac est accusé
et reconnu coupable en 2011 d'abus de
confiance de détournement de fonds
publics et de prise illégale d'intérêt
il sera condamné à deux ans de prison
avec sursis
en lui rendant hommage en soirée le
président de la république emmanuel
macron à celle lui l'humaniste le
président chirac incarne à une certaine
idée de la france une france dont il a
constamment veiller à l'unité à la
cohésion et qui l'a protégé
courageusement contre les extrêmes et la
m sur le plateau de france 2 l'ancien
premier ministre alain juppé qui a
accompagné jacques chirac pendant
plusieurs décennies à salluit ému son
ami
ce soir j'ai de la peine beaucoup de
peine jacques chirac était je ne suis
pas trouver les mots
plus qu'un ami lors de sa dernière
apparition en 2014
jacques chirac était visiblement diminué
par la maladie
le genou avait cédé la place aux vieux
lyon ce soir l'elysée a ouvert ses
portes aux français qui souhaitait
offrir leurs condoléances
une journée de deuil national se tiendra
lundi et une messe solennelle sera
célébrée à l'église saint sulpice de
paris ici marie-eve bédard radio-canada
paris